you only ANOVA does a lot of cooking she
has three children and a dog to feed
there are always some peelings or
leftovers bits of red pepper potato
skins or carrot greens in this household
the waste is sorted one category is
organic waste it's a good thing I don't
mind sorting stuff refuse should be
sorted and recycled there's a lot of
energy to be garnered when the weather's
warm the organic waste has to be taken
out before it gets smelly about 80% of
households in Berlin now have a separate
organic waste bin the city sanitation
department empties the bins and takes
their contents to the biogas plant by
the time the organic waste gets there it
stinks horribly
but the team here have got used to that
vilhelm Dinkelman is in charge
he explains that the best kind of
organic waste for His purposes stinks
more food waste which is rich in energy
unlike leaves and grass stuff that
doesn't belong here
has to be sorted out organic waste used
to be composted compost can be used on
fields or in flowerpots but there is
also a lot of energy in organic waste
and we use a process of bacterial
fermentation to access it on to
understand outdoor field
the plant uses bacteria to break down
the organic waste a mix of gases is
released including methane which can be
burned to provide heat or drive an
engine or a turbine the gases first have
to be separated and cleaned that
involves cooling to remove the moisture
the resulting biogas ninety-eight
percent methane then has to be stored
vilhelm Winckelmann helped design the
plant it's attracting a lot of attention
it could be a model for facilities
around the world but that might not be
so easy it took time and effort to
create the legal framework for the
biogas industry and its relationships to
the utilities and other sectors
we finished some heights we can use
biogas for heating to generate
electricity to power a fleet of vehicles
or sell it on the market we have a range
of options because we have the right
legal framework here in Germany other
countries don't have that and some don't
have a gas pipe grid eurosocial
undergone the berlin sanitation
department runs a hundred and fifty
garbage trucks with a gas it produces
that's hot its fleet and thus saves two
and a half million liters of diesel each
year biogas can radically reduce
greenhouse gas emissions compared to
fossil fuels it also produces much less
particulate matter than diesel so humble
potato peels can with some high-tech
help contribute to keeping the air clean